[Music]
the ex-house stands in the hills around
kabrel northeast of barcelona it's
unusual shape is best appreciated from
above a concrete building appears to be
floating it's exactly what owner de
Bourg LIGO had dreamed of hello welcome
to Barcelona welcome to my home come in
and I'll show you the house the
two-story building has 350 square meters
of living space the main living area is
on the lower floor this is our living
room where we spend lots of time with
our friends meeting up and having fun
and most of all enjoying the views which
are really awesome six meter high glass
facades allow fantastic views from every
room on Keir days you can even see the
Mediterranean
the owner chose the X shape to enable
views of both the mountains and the
scene the back of the house offers
privacy from neighbors while the front
offers panoramic views nature played an
important role in the construction of
the house we wanted to integrate it into
the project we couldn't change the
landscape because it was already there
so we had to construct the house in a
way that enabled it to fit into the
natural environment in contacto continua
meant a palace well de Berkeley Co was
planning the house with the architects
he came up with a fitting concept for
the furniture simple and modern
Glee goes favorite spot is right next to
his office on the upper floor this is
where he comes to relax clear lines and
colors dominate the interior design
combined with classics like these
Charles Eames armchairs what I love
about classic furniture is the history
behind it it's the story behind the
furniture that I like the architecture
the engineering and the people who
created it I didn't want extravagant
furniture I wanted something classic
something recognizable adjoining the
living room is a kitchen with an open
dining area the 7 meter long marble
table was designed specially for the
house it's integrated cooking surface
was tailor-made in Germany
the building's axes divided into
different kinds of living space the
house was designed by architect Eduardo
Carrabelle the concept was a challenge
as it was one of the first houses ever
built in the shape the construction
process of this house was also an
exercise in almost an experimentation we
were called by the client because we had
some experience doing concrete houses
and he wanted to test the construction
technique of shotcrete of projected
concrete that is normally used for
bridges and tunnels to build residential
spaces so the walls were projected with
concrete and then we were pouring six
metre tall walls with just one frame in
one side and the other one was was
projected the experiment was successful
not expensive the highest cost 2 million
euros to build it's mainly made of
concrete and glass in the master bedroom
the windows reach from the ceiling to
the floor when I wake up and open my
eyes the first thing I see from my bed
is the nature the position of the
bedroom is really nice and it was
conceived that way you don't see the
house or anything else you only see
nature as if you were sleeping outside
de Bourg legal and his family have lived
in the ex house for a year now enjoying
365 days of breathtaking views
[Music]